do witches go out into the woods and
worship the moon this is something that
comes up in really that's that really
happens has happen especially during
Halloween there is like a certain
connection with a moon there is certain
connection with stars with the blue moon
with the red moon with all of those
things that they believe that it opens
up in the spiritual realm so something
important to understand is that there
are principles for the spiritual realm
as I was saying with the with the blood
with the sacrifices with the it might
look like oh this is ancient this is
weird coming from a book but this is a
spiritual principles and this happens
and this is happening today this is the
saturnist they are doing it because they
understand that that there is something
so they they go out they do rituals when
there's full moon they do rituals when
there's like not even rituals just go
outside and may maybe like dancing
around because they believe and this is
why I believe as Christians we need to
step into the power and the fullness
that the Lord is giving us